Scarlett Johansson's lawsuit against Disney for
breach of contract is one of the hottest topics
in the entertainment industry right now — and
it's not hard to understand why. There are many
compelling dynamics at play. On the one hand, you
have a rich and successful movie star quibbling
over the idea that $20 million plus streaming
royalties isn't "fair compensation." Conversely,
You have a major conglomerate, arguing that
they are trying to give fans a safer way to
watch the film amid another dangerous surge
of Covid-19. It's a complex legal issue.
Regardless of which side of the fence you're on,
you probably have your own opinion on the subject.
Well, you're not alone. Dave Bautista is
not only the first celebrity to respond
to the spat between Johansson and Disney
— he's also a prominent figure in the MCU.
And he had some very interesting
things to say on the matter.
Dave Bautista has become a
popular figure in Hollywood,
especially for his role as Drax the Destroyer
in the "Guardians of the Galaxy" movies — the
success of which has led to action turns such
as this year's "Army of the Dead" on Netflix.
He's also known for being quite outspoken
for a celebrity of his stature, and fans
were dismayed to learn back in May that he
won't be reprising his beloved character
after the third and final "Guardians of the
Galaxy" movie, citing his reason for throwing
in the towel being that he is "expecting
everything to start sagging any second now."
In any case, the fact that Bautista is
getting ready to finish up his time in
the MCU didn't stop him from throwing
in his two cents about this latest
Disney controversy on social media. His
tweet, punctuated by a shrug emoji, reads,
"Told em they should've made
a #Drax movie but noooooo!"
Fans seem to be mixed on his attempt at
levity. As of this video, the tweet has
over 20,000 likes and 1,700 retweets, but in the
replies, while many followers are chuckling at his
tongue-in-cheek humor, there are also many
others who believe it to be in poor taste.
I know what you’re thinking, “People overreacting
on Twitter? NO WAY!” But yes, it really happened.
One commenter replied with, "Bad tweet.
Delete please." Another replied with
a little sarcasm of their own saying,
"Yeah, because there is a huge lack of
male superhero movies. I know it's a joke,
but it's a bad one, especially now that
Disney is trying to portray Scarlet as a
bad person when they clearly broke the contract."
There were even several chiming in pointing
to what they saw as sexism inherent in
the lawsuit, summing it up by tweeting:
"This tweet ain't it. Scarlett's contract was
breached period and she's more than entitled
to the damages they've caused her. She spend a
decade creating one of the most iconic characters,
suffered sexism and hyper sexualization
and now this crap. She deserved better."
Other Twitter users were more
supportive of Bautista's joke.
One expressed interest in a
potential Drax-centric film,
tweeting "I would have taken my butt to the
theater to see a Drax movie...repeatedly."
Another user, also backed this up with a serious
suggestion that instead of Drax getting
a movie, he should get a Disney+ series:
"Not a movie, but a tv show based on the
Infinity Watch comics. I believe it is a
better fit for a Drax spinoff. If you can mr
Bautista, try to push for that with Disney,
sell it as one more MCU show to
promote their streaming service."
Either way, the situation playing
out between Johansson and Disney
is certainly complicated — more than
just some jokes and reax on Twitter
can explain — and it may very well only get
more complicated as it plays out in court.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about MCU
controversies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don’t miss a single one.